Danny Trejo's rise to fame had quite a
few twists and turns along the way years
before he took up acting he was actually
a violent criminal who'd spent time in
multiple prisons so how was he able to
turn his life around so drastically long
before showing up in a Snickers
commercial as Marcia Brady Danny Trejo
was on the streets of Los Angeles
getting started in the criminal business
when he was just a kid he recalls that
he was only 12 when he was first tossed
into juvenile for the crime of hitting
another kid with a rock things only
escalated from there largely thanks to
his uncle Gilbert who had robbed stores
and have his nephew Danny act as the
getaway driver he would go on to commit
at least five armed robberies before he
was busted for selling a four ounce bag
of heroin worth thirty thousand dollars
as a result the 23 year old Trejo was
sentenced to 10 years and shipped off to
San Quentin where he quickly became one
of the baddest dudes behind bars after
Trejo arrived in San Quentin he quickly
made a name for himself by donning a
pair of boxing gloves and knocking bums
out he claims that prison boxing quote
literally made him a celebrity and that
he was both the lightweight and
welterweight champ in three separate
prisons and he was just as scary outside
the ring as the head of a small gang he
made quite a bit of cash by intimidating
weaker inmates forcing them to fork over
protection money naturally most people
agreed to pay up because who's gonna say
no to Danny Trejo it was also behind
bars that Trejo picked up his infamous
tattoo if you've ever seen the man
shirtless you've probably noticed the
sombrero wearing cleavage baring cowgirl
scrawled across his chest so how did
Danny Trejo go from terrifying thug to
beloved public figure his transformation
began on Cinco DeMayo 1968 when he
decided to riot it all started after
some of the Mexican inmates got a bit
inebriated and soon the prison had
erupted into madness in the chaos Trejo
hit a prison official in the head with a
rock a crime that got him tossed into
solitary confinement
Trejo spent over three months in
solitary acting out movies like The
Wizard of Oz and the Hunchback of Notre
Dom to keep saying realizing he needed
to get his life straightened out he
started to pray saying God if you're
there everything will be alright if
you're not I'm screwed
miraculously the charges against him
were dropped and he slowly but surely
began to rehabilitate himself Trejo also
turned his life around by Knuckle endow
ninh getting sober
he started using marijuana at age eight
and shooting heroin at age twelve and he
also consumed a whole lot of alcohol in
his early days determined to set things
right
he joined Alcoholics Anonymous and
Narcotics Anonymous and today he has
been sober for nearly 50 years and after
he was released from prison he decided
to lend a hand to his fellow man working
as a drug counselor for 15 years today
he is still counseling people in
speaking to at-risk youth
Trejo kept himself pretty busy after
leaving prison in 1969 working as both a
drug counselor and a court liaison but
he was forced to do all sorts of things
to pay the bills
he tried becoming a boxer but when his
license was denied he picked up some
pocket change by throwing down in
smokers aka unsanctioned matches he also
earned a living by working at a wrecking
yard before teaming up with a friend to
start his very own enterprise the two
opened a gardening business but while
they had plenty of get-up-and-go they
didn't have all the necessary equipment
they didn't even have a lawn mower
however trios tough times were soon all
about to change
in 1985 Trejo was working as a drug
counselor when he got a call from a
client who desperately needed help this
guy was working on the set of runaway
train a prison thriller starring Jon
Voight and Eric Roberts and he was
struggling with an urge to use cocaine
Trejo showed up on the set to give the
guys some assistance but it wasn't long
before someone approached Trejo and
asked if he'd like to be an extra in the
movie he took the job but as he was
changing into his outfit screenwriter
Eddie bunker spotted his chest tattoo
bunker had also served time and when he
saw the cowgirl ink
he remembered Trey hos boxing behind
bars it was an amazing coincidence
especially since the filmmakers were
looking for someone to teach Eric
Roberts how to fight I know what's at
bay and he said 320 a day
Trejo gave the actor a few pointers
which so impressed the director that he
offered Trejo a much bigger parts as the
guy who squares off against Roberts on
screen and then I remember he kissed me
give me a kiss on this cheek and in case
Andrei Konchalovsky a Russian man I
remember telling air-air Eddie
bonkers Eddie look I'm gonna do this
training for 320 but if I'm gonna be
kissing his old man
Oh more money it was tray hose first
roll the one that kick-started his
entire acting career and it was all
thanks to that Wilde tattoo ever since
runaway train Trejo has been keeping
himself pretty busy visit his IMDB page
and you'll find he's got over 300
credits in his filmography during his
30-plus years of acting he's starred
alongside some of the biggest action
stars in the business like Charles
Bronson Steven Seagal and Chuck Norris
Trejo has also appeared in some of the
biggest thrillers of all time
he played Johnny 23 in Conair a movie he
once described as the biggest case of
testosterone I've ever been in he also
showed up in the Michael Mann classic
heat as the appropriately named Trejo a
member of Robert De Niro's criminal crew
other notable credits include xxx six
days seven nights anaconda and The
Devil's Rejects plus if you've ever
turned on a TV you've no doubt seen
Trejo and shows like the x-files
Baywatch Sons of Anarchy Breaking Bad
and even the soap opera The Young and
the Restless in addition to action
flicks he's also done kid movies like
Muppets Most Wanted and comedies like
anchorman and you're gonna have to learn
how to deal with it right
are you saying something look I don't
speak Spanish cinema is full of
fantastic actor director collaborations
and Danny Trejo and Robert Rodriguez
deserve to be considered among the most
legendary pairs the two first met while
working on desperado where Rodriguez was
struck by Trey hos natural magnetism
strangely enough while working on the
film they discovered that they are
actually second cousins where do these
crazy ideas come from and after their
first film the two quickly formed a
personal and professional bond that
would lead to nine movies including Spy
Kids and from dusk till dawn but it's
safe to say the two are best known for
working on machete the 2010 exploitation
flick that definitively made Danny Trejo
a household name
rodriguez was inspired to make this nut
so be pitcher from pretty much the first
moment he laid eyes on Trejo he
envisioned his star is the quote Mexican
jean-claude Van Damme or Charles Bronson
and thus he transformed into the
machete-wielding vigilante we now know
and love you could have at least texted
me one chapter don't take once you
become the toughest star in Hollywood
where do you go next if you're Trejo you
go into the restaurant business with the
help of two partners the action star
recently founded his own culinary
Kingdom with locations across Los
Angeles if you're in the mood for
Mexican cuisine you can stop by Trey
hosts tacos if you want coffee and
churros you can drop in to Trey hosts
coffee and donuts and if you fancy a
proper drink with your meal you can
swing by Trey hos cantinas Trey hos
restaurants have vegan vegetarian and
gluten-free options and the actor makes
sure that nothing goes to waste with all
leftovers taken to a homeless shelter
Trey hos food is so good that it was
featured on Anthony Bourdain's show
parts unknown and the late great chef
had nothing but praise for the Mexican
cuisine if you live outside California
you might have to wait a bit before you
can buy yourself a lowrider donuts but
the actor has plans to open locations in
San Antonio Las Vegas and New York
everybody knows that under his
intimidating exterior Danny Trejo is a
big old softy he's a dad a drug
counselor a dude who gives food to the
homeless and naturally he's also a
big-time dog lover
in fact he's such a fan of our
four-legged friends that he's dedicated
countless hours to making the world a
safer place for pets with his ex-wife
Debbie Trejo founded a group called
canine compassion a rescue organization
that emphasizes the importance of
spaying and neutering the actor has
worked with various groups like Best
Friends Animal Society and the
Villalobos rescue center he's spoken
with high school students about proper
pet care and he's appeared in ads for
animal foundations and like any
dedicated dog lover Trejo believes in
adoption as of 2016 he had four cute
canines of his own even though Trejo is
one macho man he has his limits when it
comes to screen action in fact he's very
opinionated when it comes to the topic
of stunt work after Tom Cruise injured
himself filming mission
we'll fall out Trejo told Yahoo movies I
know that all the big stars hate me to
say this but I don't want to risk 80
people's jobs just to say I've got big
huevos on The Tonight Show
according to Trejo it's irresponsible
for a leading man or woman to jeopardize
a film shoot in order to crawl up
buildings or hold on to the side of
planes if the lead gets injured that
might ruin the entire film and then
everybody loses a paycheck Trejo may
seem like a scary guy on the big screen
but in reality he has a heart of gold
knowing full well that he packed some
serious celebrity clouds he does his
best to make a difference wherever he
goes that means working is a drug
intervention counselor fighting for
autism awareness and appearing in PSAs
to promote good manners on the LA metro
and to support male caregivers Trejo is
also incredibly serious about prison
reform going so far as to produce a 2018
documentary called survivors guide to
prison Trejo also appears in the film to
analyze the problems with the US legal
system talk about the abuse that goes on
behind bars and discuss the cases of two
men who were wrongly convicted and
incarcerated as a guy who's been on the
inside he knows a thing or two about how
cruel prison can be and how authority
figures are often indifferent to the
inmate struggling to survive Danny Trejo
is a man who likes to keep busy
and he does a whole lot more than just
appear on the silver screen for example
he's provided voices for multiple video
games
he's also recently promoted the online
shooter guns of boom train has also been
a notable star of music videos he goes
full-on psycho and Slayers pride in
prejudice and throws back some shots and
Enrique Iglesias is loco he gets pushed
around by the Jonas Brothers and burning
up and gives off serious machete vibes
and trains angel and blue jeans
in other words you don't have to look
very far to find Danny Trejo because
he's pretty much everywhere
[Music]